when you have yourself and your thorough
and confident in who you are you can
survive anywhere most people have no
idea who they are
you gotta look at it like this you're
here in life to make your mark on the
way rise and shine it's expresso time
what's up believe nation it's up in my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
on to the world so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message be yourself over
to you will smith so both our kids are
in showbiz - is that worrying for you no
you know it's you know to me showbiz is
not separated from the rules of the
universe right so whether you're in show
business or you know you're selling cars
or you're farming you know you're not
you're not separate from the laws of the
universe and all of the rules are the
same everywhere
so for you know for from my children the
most important thing is that they be
encouraged to fully and thoroughly be
themselves no matter what and when you
when you have yourself and you're
thorough and confident in who you are
you can survive anywhere be yourself is
one of the most powerful pieces of
advice you could follow but it's also
one of the most difficult it's one of
the most difficult because most people
have no idea who they are they have an
inkling you have a little bit of
knowledge of a little bit of sense about
it but deep down you still don't really
know because we're constantly living our
life based of what our parents want us
to do or our friends where we see on
Instagram or YouTube we don't know who
we truly are self awareness is the
single most important key to unlock in
your potential
and most people have no idea it's why I
wrote your one word it's why I wrote the
book because I think it's really
important to figure out what your most
important core value is if you don't
know what your most important core value
is how do you live life how do you
create a life and a business for those
of you entrepreneurs around something
meaningful important to you what do you
chase see and one of the most important
things that I say in the book is I don't
want you talking to other people about
your one word yet while you're still
discovering it while you're figuring out
that process don't go talking to other
people because whoever you're talking to
they only see one side of you or maybe a
couple sides to you but nobody sees
everything even your wife your husband
your best friends your parents nobody
sees everything and the key here is
spending less time asking other people
what they think about you what they
think your core value is what they know
about you and spend more time with
yourself to get the self-awareness you
need to spend more time with yourself to
figure out your most important core
value you need to spend more time with
yourself and so for people who have
figured it out they know that one word
or they they know how to be themselves
then amazing the world is yours the the
path is clear the goals are clear it's
easy you stop to go and do the work do
you have the courage do you have the
confidence do you have the resources are
you going to get up every day and do the
habits that go and chase your goals but
at least the path is clear for those of
you who don't know for those of you
don't know what your most important core
values are for those of you who feel
like you don't know yourself then what
are you waiting for
whether you use my strategy your
one-word or whether you use another path
you need to figure it out at least in my
mind I don't know how you operate I
don't know how you can keep going
through life without knowing who you are
hoping that something magical is gonna
happen it won't you get what you attract
you have to know what to attract to
bring the people in to help you go off
and build something amazing whether
that's a huge company or whether that's
just having
great family life and being a great
father what does it mean to be a great
father what does it mean to be a great
husband or great wife or great mother or
great child it all stems from you
knowing yourself and so if you have
found that for yourself amazing I love
it this is the beginning of a path to
excellence to create an extraordinary
life and if you don't know what it is
then make it your immediate priority
make it your immediate priority the
figure out who you are you can start
with your one word or if you don't like
that concept then find another path but
figure out who you are what you stand
for and then how you can bring that to
building extraordinary life because you
deserve it
because you should not be walking around
another day on this planet without
understanding who you are and how to
build an extraordinary life now I've got
some really special bonus clips for you
but before that question of the day I
want to know what is your most important
core value what is your one word leave
it down the comments below really
curious if I know thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of an espresso and enjoy
the bonus clips
[Music]
you got to look at it like this your
hair and life to make your mark on the
world so at the end of the day be
yourself and be everything that you
desire to be that you that is your own
you know because at the end of the day
the second you try to be like somebody
else to follow somebody else that's all
you can be you know I'm saying you'll
never be able to see the potential of
yourself so be yourself I haven't had
any regrets you know and it there and
it's sometimes really hard I'll tell you
a funny story I remember right before I
got a different world I auditioned for
blossom remember the TV show absolutely
yes
you remember her friend the young girl
her six I auditioned for six okay and I
had my hair up in a little ponytail with
this little jumpsuit I looked like I was
about 12 got the role okay
got the role to play six and I was like
I was 18 19 years old then I said I
looked at my agent Nancy ran for it
I said Nancy I can't do this I just
can't do it this is I'm gonna be
miserable playing a twelve-year-old on
this show I can't do this and we had to
turn it down and I and let me tell you
then folks were not happy it's like this
girl this she is you know that whole
thing but within two weeks I got a
different world and that really taught
me a lesson which was you know to really
listen to and and follow my gut because
everything that that shines isn't gold
you know what I mean and so it really
taught me a very valuable lesson to just
stay true to myself if there's nothing
that I haven't learned about this
business it's really about staying true
to why I'm here why you know I started
acting in the first place and and what's
important to me and keeping my artistic
integrity as well as my creative like my
personal Integra
and that was a big lesson for me and let
me tell you that was not an easy thing
to turn down you know being a young
actress you got this opportunity for you
know this this series regular is money
you know but I just felt deep it down
inside I was like something's coming
your way just fall back and then I got
to meet you know Debbie Allen I really
think creativity is important whether
whatever you do I think it's fun to be
creative with meals that you cook or
meals that you eat or vacations that you
go on or dates that you said you know I
just think it's fun to be creative
everyone likes that and I think
authenticity is just super important I
might be hyper aware of it because I
grew up in an industry that's wrought
with inauthenticity that people will
look you right in the face and and
totally tell you what you need to hear
at the moment I don't think that's
unique to that industry but it's filled
with it there so I I think transparency
and authenticity is just super important
I don't mind having conflict with
someone if we can then be done with it
it's that years spent where you know
that something's going on and you're not
talking about it those awful
Thanksgivings with the family of cousins
or you're like hey Jim hey Neela I hate
that I hate that life's too short for
that stuff raise your standard Apple at
the core its core values is that passion
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your it's suppose to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rows of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details